اتجاه تصاعدي تتخذه الهزات الارتداديه
التي اعقبت زلزال سوريا وتركيا عددا وقوه
حيث وقعت اكثر من سته الاف واربعين هزه
ارتداديه وصلت قوه احداها لسته فاصل اربعه
درجه اي بمثابه زلزال اخر هذه الحقائق
اضيفت الى تحليلات تهويليه وتنبؤات بان
الهزات هي تمهيد لزلزال اكبر واقوى لكن ما
هي الهزات الارتداديه وهل فعلا هناك زلزال
اخر متوقع اكثر تدميرا وفق خبراء
جيولوجيين كلما كانت الهزه الاساسيه قويه
كلما تبعتها هزات ارتداديه اكثر على مدى
اطول يمتد احيانا لايام واسابيع وحتى اشهر
فعند وقوع زلزال قوي يتحرك قسم كبير من
الفالق الزلزالي المسبب ولكن ليس بالكامل
وبالتالي القسم الذي لم يتحرك سيواصل تح
بعد الزلزال لحين عوده الارض الى طبيعتها
وهو ما يسبب الهزات الارتداديه خبراء
اكدوا ان بعض الهزات لم تكن ارتداديه بل
هزات مستقله حدثت على فوالق اخرى نتيجه
ضغط تسبب به الزلزال الكبير على ما يحيط
من فوالق اما التحذير من امكانيه وقوع
زلزال اقوى فاحتماليته ضعيفه وفق علماء
بحكم عدم اتصال الفوالق لا سيما ان
الزلزال القوي الذي ضرب قبل اسبوعين حرر
القسم الاكبر من الطاقه الضاغطه فيما
القسم الاخر ينتقل من مكان الى اخر ويحدث
الاهتزازات